kubernetes allows you to focus on the
applications that matter to you by
abstracting away clusters of underlying
infrastructure but when an application
is stateful meaning it needs to persist
data in some form it can be essential to
have greater control over that
underlying infrastructure today we're
going to explore tools for running
stateful workloads in gke
[Music]
first let's explore what a stateful
workload is in the context of kubernetes
to put it simply a state full workload
is typically one that stores some form
of data that needs to persist meanwhile
a state less one does not necessarily
store data and often could be disrupted
for a short time without major
consequence
from its Beginnings kubernetes has been
well suited to managing stateless
workloads when a workload does not need
to maintain state it can generally be
disrupted and spun back up with minimal
Interruption to the service
kubernetes is very good at Auto healing
these types of use cases generally when
running stateless workloads we don't get
too attached to any specific instance of
the workload or of the hardware if and
when a workload fails kubernetes will
automatically replace it with a new one
in the case of State full workloads the
workload will have constant data
persistent needs of some sort the
workload may have significant
dependencies on underlying Hardware as
it writes data to disk
these rights may be long-lived meaning
that the workload cannot simply be
disrupted and spun back up any
disruption must be handled gracefully to
avoid any potential for data loss as a
managed kubernetes service gke provides
the normal open source tools for
managing stateful workloads such as
persistent volumes and persistent volume
claims pod disruption budgets or pdbs
and node affinity for ensuring stateful
workloads have access to the hardware
they need however there are also a
number of considerations beyond the
cluster itself where gke can provide
additional help
for example cluster backup Services
built-in observability features to
ensure safe upgrades and the
infrastructure options to make sure your
stateful workloads have the hardware
they need
let's explore some of these useful tools
and features backups are a key
consideration for stateful workloads
anywhere the backup for gke service
ensures you can backup your kubernetes
workloads safely it provides the ability
to backup not only the persistent
volumes containing the data for your
apps running in kubernetes but also the
configuration of the gke cluster itself
another important functionality in gke
is upgrades gke has a few upgrade tools
that can help you run stateful workloads
with minimal disruption across upgrades
the first I'll talk about here is
release channels the rapid regular and
stable channels provide a regular
Cadence at varying frequencies to ensure
your clusters are getting updated to
maintain supportability
with the pace of the kubernetes project
it can be challenging to both keep up
with supported versions and at the same
time ensure minimal disruption from
version changes for your workloads
release channels and gks related release
management tooling helps you maintain
both uptime and supportability one
important way gke ensures you can safely
keep your clusters on supported updated
gke versions is with deprecation
insights and recommendations when gke
detects that a cluster is using a
kubernetes feature or API that is
deprecated and will be removed in an
upcoming minor version it pauses any
auto upgrades to that upcoming minor
version and provides recommendations to
help you assess and mitigate potential
issues a common approach to ensure a
smooth transition during an upgrade is
to use a blue green strategy gke offers
native blue-green node pool upgrade
functionality
a blue-green node pool upgrade will spin
up a full set of new nodes so you can
test workloads on the new version before
completing a node pool upgrade
using a blue green strategy for upgrades
can be particularly helpful in stateful
use cases where continuity and stability
are especially important be sure to
check out our video on GK node pool
upgrades to learn more about the
strategies and tools to help you upgrade
your clusters safely when it comes to
making sure your kubernetes workloads
have the storage they need gke has a
number of options to fulfill a variety
of needs for NFS Cloud file store can
provide persistent storage for multiple
readers and writers GK also provides
options for configuring persistent disks
for your cluster with flexible sizes and
for those workloads that need high
performance at very low latency you can
configure locally attached ssds for the
workloads in your gke clusters from
backups to upgrades to configuring
storage to suit your needs gke provides
an ecosystem of solutions to support the
challenges of running stateful workloads
in kubernetes in this video you learned
about what stateful means for workloads
running in kubernetes and about the
ecosystem of tools features and Services
gke provides to help you run your
stateful workloads safely with the
concepts discussed in this video we're
confident you'll be on your way to
building a gke cluster that suits your
needs you can get started with gke by
visiting the Google Cloud console and
checking out the links below stay tuned
for our next videos where we dive deeper
into gke topics
[Music]
foreign foreign